should religious scientists live under a
cloud of Suspicion
and if their religion informs their
science what are we to make of that is
it contaminated and I think it's very
important to recognize that there are
multiple ways of being a scientist who
happens to be religious
um
and I've learned this over time so I've
been wrong on this topic and I've in
coming into contact with higher quality
scientists motivated by religion
I've come to understand that there's a
sub population that is very special and
interesting
and it's effectively a population of
people who agreed to the rules of
science they're not going to cheat on
the rules of science because Jesus
but they are going to use the idea of
purpose and a personal relationship with
God to give them courage to question
things that are essentially
unquestionable
within the union of scientists that will
get you thrown out of the Union of
scientists very quickly as to your point
so what we're talking about is we're
talking about relatively
self-destructive
scientists focused on science who get
their courage
from religion and some of their bearings
and their focus
so for example
um
many of these people do not believe that
there's a persuasive case for random
mutation as being the major engine
of selection
they believe that it is simply
improbable and they point to very often
the wistar Conference held at the
University of Pennsylvania at the Westar
Institute and they they try to say this
is a live issue where the books got
closed prematurely and in fact it's the
atheists according to them who were led
into error because they were trying to
close the books desperately so as not to
leave any Gap large enough for a God to
be smuggled into the Canon of science
I am persuaded that the Richard Dawkins
of the world who have contributed in my
estimation hugely to modern evolutionary
theory are so afraid of dealing with
religious colleagues
that they were eager to shut the books
and not give many of these people their
due
and what's more
the concept of intelligent design is a
really interesting one now my brother
who uh I think has just brilliant in
terms of phrase and insights into
evolutionary theory one of his
Richard Dawkins I think wants to be
remembered for the meme not not as the
uh the the military the gift that gets
sent over to Twitter but the meme and
the extended phenotype is his greatest
contributions and I think one of Brett's
um better ideas is understanding
perception-mediated selection
it is very clear that when you have
various breeds of dog they are
intelligently designed when you produce
a mule from a donkey and a horse that is
not a natural animal
you are producing an intelligently
designed animal when you create Orchid
varieties
so in all of these cases you have to
admit that darwinian theory has
perception mediated selection the
display of bowerbirds where they build
these structures and Adorn them with
blue in some cases
perception mediated selection is a form
of endogenous design which is
intelligent because it is mediated
through perception right it's a good
place to study it because the words
intelligent design have been made
radioactive right and so what we're
arguing about is should the should the
books have been closed uh with the
neo-darwinian synthesis or should they
have been left open
and I have to say I really think that
without the religious scientists
who are willing to destroy themselves in
their careers but who still do not wish
their love of a benevolent God or a
fearsome Old Testament God or or a
personal Jesus Christ
I believe that many of those people are
responsible for prying the Books open
when Dawkins and Company wished to close
them prematurely and I'm honestly
sympathetic with the Dawkins perspective
I cannot stand what I've called Jesus
smuggling
where you're in some very careful
argument and you know you've set
everything up and then somebody sort of
says well I just believe that God's love
pervades everything you're saying Oh
Brother do I really have to listen to
this
um on the other hand
going toe-to-toe with some of these
religious scientists is an eye-opening
experience because they are highly
motivated not to got they know that
they're Heretics and if you think about
let's say
um Galileo's heresy
they are in some sense the Heretics of
today and their reputations are burned
at the stake they're not they're not
Bruno in uh 1600s in the Square but I
think that what we have to say is
that many of these people are making
points that atheists wish would go away
what is the strongest or something give
me a couple of uh arguments from design
that appeal intellectually well I I'm
particularly motivated by two systems uh
in perception mediated selection one of
which has to do with the lamp basilis
muscle
which uh
produces a meaty lip that extends
outside of its shell in clearly the form
of a bait fish for bass and clear
streams and when a bass swims by the
muscle Wiggles this little piece of meat
that is outside and it looks exactly
like a fish in the Stream
and the bass sometimes fall for it and
sometimes see the ruse but if they fall
for it
the bass
clamps down on the lip and all of the
young of the muscle of the lampasillis
muscle
diffuse into the gills of the bass clamp
on to get a blood meal and are taken
away by the bass to distribute them in
the Stream where the muscle doesn't have
the ability to spread its young
there's no way you can tell me that that
isn't an intelligently designed system
and it's the bass that is the
intelligence
and the bass is specifically designing
its own
fooling its own it's self-deception
because Dumber bass fell for this trick
before and smarter bass didn't fall for
it and that pushes The Selective
pressures in order to produce this now
there's a closely related system that is
not based on predation which is the bass
system that is based on sexual
reproduction and that has to do with the
ofrees system in orchids so there's this
one sort of clade of orchids
um
where no I talk about this a lot Darwin
I asked the question one day what did
Darwin do after Origin of Species like
how do you follow yourself for Encore
and he wrote this book which I couldn't
believe the title which was on the
various contrivances by which British
and foreign orchids are fertilized by
insects and I thought that is the
dumbest thing I can possibly imagine but
Darwin being Darwin was incredibly smart
or orchids are incredibly speciated and
therefore they're a great system in
which to study various mechanisms now if
you read that Darwin does not understand
why the ofrey's Orchid
makes a replica of the species that
pollinate it
particularly the females with using its
lowest of five petals I believe and
producing incredible pheromones that are
almost indistinguishable from the
pheromones produced by a female who's
receptive to mating
and you watch Darwin trying to figure
out why this would be and he can't
figure out that this is actually a
consequence of his own Theory because
the theory is too new and it's just like
one of the most beautiful vignettes and
nobody talks about it and so what I
would say is
in that situation a male tries to
copulate with the flower not realizing
that it's not a female
if it's fooled twice then the flowers
don't have to give up an expense an
energetically expensive nectar meal
and they can they can be very cheap
about it all they have to do is to offer
an erzot's sexual experience and this is
called pseudo copulation so in both of
these systems
if you look at the mirror Orchid for
example it's a stunning replica with
hair and the shininess on the back and
this whole the whole thing you can tell
what is fooling the pollinator now both
of these are systems in which that which
is dumber is fooling that which is
smarter using the intelligence the
bounded intelligence of the thing being
fooled to intelligently design a trap
and both of these are effectively
parasites because they're stealing
energy
from the dupe
and that energy is used to further the
species in an antagonistic fashion
um
if I make that point and I say actually
intelligent design is all through the
animal kingdom it's just not what you
think it's not a question of an initial
Creator who's deciding you know then
move mood or saying you're an aardvark
you're a eucalyptus tree
so endogenous intelligent design is
essential to darwinian Theory within
Brett's context of perception-mediated
selection
and then what do you get from the uh
atheistic science communities like we
will have no such discussion
[Music]
foreign